the intersectionality is the other kind
of big phenomenon I talk the
intellectual phenomenon which holds that
you know the oppressed are the experts
on their own oppression so within a
circle activist the person who has the
most layers of oppression is going to be
looked to for guidance no one else is
allowed to speak on these issues in fact
[Music]
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me on the
Rubin report today is an editor at
Reason magazine and the author of the
new book panic attack young radicals in
the age of Trump Robbie suave
welcome to the Rubin report thank you
for having me before we do anything else
here I have a strict policy that we
don't let people on the show at higher
hair and yet you've come in here with
higher hair I'm very upset I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry you dressed like Jordan
Peterson you you stepped up the action
game you got nothing going on right now
I should have come in sneakers and
shorts and t-shirt which is what I
usually do yeah what kind of libertarian
I don't know man I'm trying to class up
the idea of of libertarianism all right
so there's a ton I want to talk about I
really enjoyed the book here and you you
sort of really get on the inside of a
lot of the ideas that I'm talking about
on this show relative to college
campuses and just sort of the fraying of
politics and all these kind of micro
groups on the left and right that are
popping up all over the place but first
off you are an editor at Reason magazine
which is sort of the libertarian
standard is that fair to say something
like that certainly when did you become
a libertarian so I'm one of those boring
origin stories where I grew up in like a
Republican household but my parents
never really cared about social issues
and we're basically libertarians without
knowing the word for it and then
realized when I found out basically what
libertarianism was when I went to
college that oh yeah that's me so that's
my I pretend I'm like no my father was
born in like a seasteading platform no
no boring boring origin story just
discovered that it was what fit my views
so as people say to me all the time Dave
you're not really a classical liberal
you're not a liberal anymore you're a
libertarian I don't mind being called a
libertarian obviously but do you see any
meaningful distinction between classical
liberal and libertarian cuz this comes
up all the time and I'm curious what the
libertarians think of that I would say
not really one of the things about
libertarian classically liberal people
is that the belief in individual rights
is our sort of most important thing so
that tends to I think the people who are
attracted to the ideas of individual
liberty tend to be against like forming
big groups and coalition's
so they start to they start to that
would explain the Libertarian Party I
think what exactly they get skittish
when there's too many other people
calling themselves libertarians ago well
I only agree with that person on
ninety-nine point seven percent of
things what about the other point three
percent so then they want to say well
I'm a classical liberal or libertarian
or I'm an individualist liberal or I'm a
I'm an anarcho-capitalist or so there's
a lot of fracture fracturing that is
just what happens when you have people
who are drawn to the idea of
individualism trying to form a larger
group so in a weird way is that sort of
the ultimate Achilles heel of anyone
that cares about Liberty that to then
coordinate around Liberty I guess the
founders were able to do it somehow and
had real disagreements on exactly what
that meant but sort of in a modern sense
when there's so many different ideas of
what freedom is and now we have 300 some
odd million people that live in this
country but it's really hard to get a
unifying principle I mean that sort of
does explain the naked guy running
around at the libertarian convention I
just sort of the general lunacy because
I would love to see a strong libertarian
party or a classical liberal party
saying but it doesn't seem like like I
see no like Avenue to get there you know
right I mean yeah I mean the thing is I
think many people maybe even most people
have a lot of libertarian impulses they
want to be left alone broadly they want
to leave you alone as long as we're not
hurting each other it's fine they like
the idea of the government being small
in the abstract but then when it comes
to specific issues a lot of people don't
necessarily you know connect these
things ago well I want a small
government but all we need Medicare and
we need and you know what about these
other countries we need to make sure
they're doing the right thing so it's
it's the principles not being applied I
think across the board that's what
libertarians are always trying to make
you do apply that same thinking about
this issue where you say yeah it's fine
they can do whatever they want it
doesn't affect me to everything the
government does
and then you'd be a libertarian so do
you think most of its just that people
don't think about these issues that hard
cuz I'm sort of with you on that but
generally when I've talked to people
that say are more progressive or
something when you really get them to
understand like oh you want it so you
won't just want to live your life how
you want you want gay people to be
treated okay you want a smoker you want
to smoke the rest of it like actually
those are not things that the
government's giving you the government
you just have nothing to do with them
like that there is a way to get through
to them well most exactly and most
people don't spend a lot of time
thinking about public policy in general
or educating themselves about public
policy for very good reasons because
it's pointless they have life you know
they're they're busy becoming doctors
and lawyers and taking care of their
family and providing value to society
the this is an idea that comes from
economics right this is the the
rationally irrational voter the person
who's not well informed about public
policy because there's no reason it
doesn't there's no incentive for you to
become well informed because in the end
of day you only get one vote right so if
you just spend all your time like
educating yourself about this it doesn't
help you that much is that the the sort
of ultimate Achilles heel then that it's
like if you're a libertarian or you care
about individual liberty granted stuff
it's like if you were gonna find a
candidate that you liked the candidate
would basically be like I don't want
anything to do with you and that's a
pretty hard way to run a campaign and
then the candidate there's no guarantee
the candidate keeps these ideas when
they get into it that's probably well
that will is that even if you get the
right person in well then the the
regulatory capture of government just
turns them into another they'll be very
selective on a couple issues they'll
still talk about you know the need to
protect individual liberty but then
they'll become a big government crony
person on every other issues not all the
time but it happens most of the time
Rand Paul is pretty good though on this
stuff right I mean yeah he's trying to
do it from within the Republican Party
which Rand Paul has definitely decided
that being a kind of advocate of Trump
and pushing Trump in a libertarian
direction on a few very specific issues
most notably foreign policy is the
strategy he's going to use I think there
are I think there are problems with that
strategy but also good things about it
and he has been I'm glad he's there you
know pushing Trump to be more the thing
I liked
most about Trump right what's his
foreign-policy was his was his idea that
the Iraq war was a mistake that we
shouldn't be nation-building and the the
sort of normal people inside the
Republican Party that never went away
from the previous administration are
trying to push Trump to not do that to
me just kind of another neoconservative
and Rand Paul has been one of the only
people you know kind of in a very
flattering Trump way like hey you're
great don't you remember who everybody
loves you cuz you're you're not that
right do you think he's making good
headway there I mean it's still even
with some of the Iran stuff right now
like I don't think we're going to war
and I think there's a lot of big talk
but it does seem to me that Trump is
upholding yeah we're not gonna nation
build and we're not you know we're
talking to North Korea yeah I mean if
this was Obama people would be going
crazy so there is some good stuff there
there is some good stuff I wish they
could have stopped
Boulton from having any influence of the
administration Pompeyo was more of a
neocon type person but I I'm glad
there's somebody doing it you know Trump
this is one issue where I think his
instincts yeah I disagree with Trump on
a lot of things where I think his
instincts are actually better men's
people around him this right one thing
well they just did what he thought was
right on the military dimension of
foreign policy do you think he possibly
puts those guys in like a guy like
Bolton who's thought of as this hawk so
that it seems like you're gonna go to
war at any moment but in actuality it's
like that's the exact reason you don't
go to war you know it's sort of like
this is where his people would be like
oh well that's the 4d chess move you're
right you say that is the for detail but
there is some truth to it if you just if
you keep bringing in all these piece
Knicks well then your enemies know that
they can mess with you where it's like
you're bringing a guy like Bolton and
it's like whoa we got Bolton and Trump
at it at any moment they could do
something nuts that could be but I think
Trump is just so much more personality
driven than we all you know we are
policy politics people so and so many in
the media do that they try to think of
what's Trump's doing in terms of just
sort of politics or what political
calculus he's making but I think he
makes a lot of decisions based on who he
likes or who he gets along with it I
mean I'm not faulting that approach
either the the just it's all politics
and all policy approach obviously leads
people astray all the time right so it's
just a different kind of thing where I
think he plays it by ear I think he can
be talked into
and out of things based on the rapport
he has with various people so and I
think that partly explains what what
Rand Paul is doing possibly to his
credit yeah all right before we get too
far into the book yes you spoke to
Congress correct
I did and then something crazy happened
you told Congress that white supremacy
is not completely running rampant that
was in essence
well you said what was the title of the
short it was a Asian that you spoke it
was a subcommittee meeting before the
house of the house civil liberties and
civil rights committee and I discussed
with a number of other panel members the
the ostensible rise in hate crimes and
white nationalism I was brought I was
the one Republican would not not a
Republican but I was brought by the
Republicans to offer some kind of
counter perspective to the the experts
they had who were all talking as if
there is this rise in hate crimes and I
was kind of contextualizing the numbers
you know obviously hate crimes are
terrible and I'm not saying they don't
exist which is exactly what you said to
them but the idea that they are off the
charts higher than they've ever been and
that it directly is because of Trump or
Trump's rhetoric or something it's just
not there's not a lot of good data to
actually support that the FBI is
tracking of hate crimes is actually just
really bad they're counting like 7,000
hate crimes not all agencies report some
agencies that probably do have hate
crimes just report zero it's an optional
reporting thing actually if you go back
to 1996 there are more hate crimes being
reported then just for fewer agencies
than there are now so you know it goes
up it fluctuates it's just not a very
good number we just doesn't really give
us a very impression of anything which
is what I said actually the other people
who were testifying pretty much agreed
with that I mean this was not like a
fireworks session we had some we had
some disagreements but yeah the
important thing was this was a civil
liberties subcommittee in addition
everything else I just want you know
when we're discussing how to confront
hate crimes hate incidents some things
that actually aren't crimes but are but
it starts to impugn on speech and things
like that that we understand if we're
creating like we're empowering the FBI
to watch more people to do that kind of
thing there are civil liberties
trade-offs and we have to be a little we
can't just say rah rah we're gonna fight
hate harder we the government
and there's gonna be no downsides to
that approach whatsoever that's all I
really wanted us to recognize and
broadly that's what happened right we're
gonna fight hate because that's it
that sounds like a winnable fight all
right you're on hate the war on hate
that's the war we're gonna fight so the
people that were taking the counter of
that though even though you're saying
that privately maybe they were agreeing
with you a little bit or maybe not that
hysterical if you listen to the media I
mean if you listen to mainstream media
it seems that the white supremacists are
everywhere the KKK is everywhere
Westboro Baptist Church and all of these
things were they making any statistical
arguments or was it just sort of a
general you know vague sense of well we
see more of this or there's more anger
on Twitter or something like that
because that seems to be what the
argument is about these days right it's
never about numbers and if you if you
use numbers usually call the Nazi well
and they put out numbers that are just
easily abused like the Southern Poverty
Law Center has loved those guys well
right you know they probably consider
Southern Poverty hate centers but
they're you know I've looked at their
chart and their chart shows you know
more it's a map of the United States
more hate groups than ever but if you
click on any state you're gonna see like
okay well how many people are actually
in this group you know maybe it's like a
souvenir shop that sells confederate
memorabilia or something that that's
like two people maybe this group was
four people and they had a fight and now
it's two groups so now it's more that
was before and are you looking at I'm
looking state-by-state and many of these
states half of these groups are actually
black nationalist groups which again I
think present no threat whatsoever
they're again nine crazy people yelling
it to you at the street like the like
the group that yelled at the Covington
kids in DC you know just a lot of lack
is really right a lot of wackos out
there but that their group you know
increased a certain amount doesn't
doesn't show that there's some massive
spike in hate crimes that kind of stuff
the the number of groups like that Pro
Jewish groups put out statistics showing
well there's an Inc there was an
increase in maybe anti-semitic
harassment but actually anti-gay her
somatic violence was down and actually
all these threats were made by this one
like crazy teen who lived in Israel this
was the guy who called in the bomb
threats to racism right so that
okay that's bad and all these things
might be bad but do not speak to the
kind of massive rise in hate that would
be caused by Trump which is what they're
they're making a political connection
there so to really bring this to a
libertarian place when you go and talk
to these people and Congress has these
sort of meetings and hearings all the
time the people that are listening
well first off it's hard to tell how
many people are actually listening when
when people are talking you know there's
a lot of people on their phones in the
back of the rest of it but like do you
actually think that what you're saying
is getting through to the members of
Congress that are they're like what do
you what is the intention behind okay
you go and you say your piece and that's
nice and it can get clipped and shared
and hopefully some sane people hear it
and then I they realize that oh my god
the Nazis aren't coming okay that's fine
but do you think that the members of
Congress that are there are actually
doing anything with this information or
is this just busy work for them it's
like what am I gonna do today I'll sit
on a panel of white supremacy like what
are they doing yeah it's promotion for
them right so they want that clip of
them asking a tough question and looking
very tough on this issue for instance
there was a now now this or now next or
one of those aggressive twitter video
they so they took a video of aoc who
briefly chaired this committee actually
toward the end and they had a clip of
her asking this tough quite there was
always perfectly legitimate question she
was saying why do some of these
incidents get that are that have to do
with Islamic extremism get marked
terrorism and these having to do with
white supremacy didn't get marked
terrorism and that actually seemed like
a perfectly but the person before her
another Democrat had just asked the same
thing like the exact same thing but she
needs to her saying it again I'm not
even faulting the questioning was
perfectly fine again this was a fine
hearing but everyone is just operating I
think under the incentives that now look
at me I'm being tough on this issue this
will be good for me Republicans
Democrats it's the same thing it's not a
partisan issue but yeah these were these
were hearings probably for a for a
promotional purpose for the people
holding up right so the reason actually
that I mention all of this is because so
you go up there you do your thing you
lay out some statistics and you were you
did not deny that racism exists just as
you said right here
you laid out some pretty sort of what I
would say are just base level arguments
in the good sense right but then the
Huffington Post decided to go after you
this author at The Huffington Post went
after you implying that you're sort of
denying that hey it exists and all of
these things and the reason I mentioned
all of that is because this happened I'm
lady we're gonna mention the guy's name
unless you want to it's not worth it now
but it happens to be the same author at
The Huffington Post who a couple weeks
ago and I invited mayor Pete Budaj on
the show was immediately tweeting at him
to not do my show because you know I'm a
scary evil whatever it is he was saying
about me and I thought these people the
way these guys operate this these fo
journalists that's far more dangerous
than the rise of white supremacy in
America and at least in my opinion and
in both these instances he's trying to
say that there this this HuffPost author
was trying to say that there should be
no dialogue between these two people
between you and and Budaj edge and
between me and the other panelists
because it's triggering or makes people
unsafe or it's it's so horrible when
when we would have both in both
situations you would have had a great
conversation you would have learned
mayor Pete would have learned I learned
from listening to people even though I
didn't agree with them for instance that
thing about classifying some groups as
terrorists and something I didn't know
that before that's kind of interesting I
there might be some legitimate issues
there they'll I had a very nice
conversation with one of the panelists
was of the mother of the of the woman
who died at Charlottesville of terrible
and she was a lovely woman
very courageous speaker you know we
talked after the far from that the
HuffPost author said how you know how
horrible it was that she had to sit
anywhere near me this person who's
denying that white supremacy even exist
said it very much exists but we had a
very nice conversation I learned from
her I told her about Reason magazine so
you know difficult conversations and
this wasn't even even a difficult
conversation but conversations between
people with different different
perspectives or a good thing I mean
that's done I have an ideology that's
kind of that right yeah and that's a
very important part of classical
liberalism so it's just it's it's
frustrating and crazy for for me to see
someone like again this author
contending that it's just it's just
wrong
on its face or it's dangerous or it
makes it it's it's a it's a form of
discomfort bordering on violence which
this conversation which ironically of
course what they're doing is actually
fermenting more of it because if they're
gonna say that a guy like you is too
fringed to talk at a panel like this I
mean that's what that's what they're
doing to me it's like all right if these
two guys are two friends you know I mean
it's like well then who is left and they
just keep moving but what do you think
more broadly about just sort of the way
journalists are operating there there
are a million examples of HuffPo and Vox
and BuzzFeed and the rest of them doing
this sort of thing taking sort of
mainstream thought or something that's
politically incorrect but but factually
true and an uncomfortable truth let's
say and trying to pin the people who say
it is awful when it's not their job to
do that right this guy's a reporter not
a columnist right as far as I know right
Twitter unfortunately or maybe
fortunately has allowed a lot of these
extensively neutral or objective or
straight news writers to reveal or kind
of almost like hello in their eyes
unmask themselves pretty much try not to
you know paint with a broad brush
because there are people at all of these
various media institutions doing great
work and friends with many of them I
like a lot of what they have to do and
even you know people who get things
wrong sometimes can be right other times
so I try to be a little careful when I
you know characterize the media but you
are seeing a level of I think because
Trump has positioned himself or to some
degree the media has positioned Trump
this way it's Trump versus the media
which is which is a a framing that Trump
himself likes mm-hmm
so then it's it's hard you're not no
longer like the like the score keeper or
the referee
if you're the opposing team I mean I'm
making a sports metaphor very simple I
know about two teams and a referee yeah
I could have made any metaphor there you
know you want to do something that fits
within your lifestyle so Game of Thrones
so you have a so so anyway because the
media is in the oppositional camp
there's a kind of media solidarity or
there's a there's an extra
I think hunger to fight well what's the
Trump there with the anti-trump angle
and the story and I this is this can be
a tough thing and you know sometimes I
agree with the media sometimes I agree
with the Trump people but even me
they're like well are you on which team
are you in right how do you how do what
you're like with the Covington stuff for
instance that was exampled me saying the
kids that you know and I wrote a lot
about how they hadn't really been the
media had mischaracterized what happened
to them but I'm not saying that from
like like a pro Trump way or anything
and it's just it was hard for both sides
to understand why are you the which team
are you on which is so ironic because I
think that and that's that is
interesting about you because I follow
you on twitter we've met before and I
don't I know what your feelings are on
Liberty let's say and freedom and
individual rights and all that it's but
I don't like that but like I don't know
exactly like I wouldn't say you're a
trump supporter per se or or or a sort
of Trump derangement syndrome person and
that and I think people sort of think
that about me too and then because of
that you just get it constantly from
from both sides which I guess is it
means you're doing something right thank
you
I believe I have to believe that all
right let's let's shift to the book a
little bit because you really dope into
the college craziness which obviously we
talk a lot about on this on this show
was there a specific incident that you
were suddenly like holy cow I have to
write the book about that because
there's just like this endless cascade I
mean every day like that the stuff that
happened to Christakis and Yale the the
the Dean who was confronted by this sort
of mob of students because his wife had
like sent an email to the campus saying
you know maybe you can wear whatever you
want on Halloween it's not a big deal
yeah Jesus Christ and a couple weeks ago
right true radical this guy that was I
think maybe the galvanizing incident for
this sort of phase of campus sort of
political correctness outrage whatever
you want to call it or the media people
in the right leaning meeting also people
in the mainstream media paying more
attention to this issue you know the
stuff what happened to Weinstein all
those things
and you know my question was more than
just you know criticizing these students
which is easy to do and we all do that
trying to understand like like okay but
why are you doing this like what when
did you decide this was a good tactic
for getting what you want hmm and I sort
of through the process of writing the
book kind of increasingly came to the
point of view that they don't actually
see it the way I was thinking of it is
like don't you aren't you trying to
persuade people and you think this is
right they're not thinking of it in
those terms they're thinking of it in
terms of self-defense that if you are
bringing someone to speak on campus
who's going to make people feel
uncomfortable even a small number of
people uncomfortable or you yourself
make people uncomfortable because of
what you think or what you say emotional
or psychological discomfort or is on the
same spectrum of kind of vile of
physical violence of true love true
violence so if you're doing that then
you've engaged in violence even less so
even on like libertarian grounds right
you can practice self-defense if someone
attacks you you can you can fight back
you just can't start you can't start
fights that's like the classically
liberal value well they're saying well
you started the fight you threw the
first punch because you brought this
person who makes people feel unsafe so
the the sort of radical new
understanding of safety is at the heart
of so much of the kind of culture that
has changed on cam were you able to
figure out what the genesis of that is
like where did that idea really come
from that speech is violence because we
see it all over the place right which
then leads you to oh label someone a
Nazi and then what do you have to do
when you see a Nazi right you punch your
Nazi right campuses are very safe places
actually so at I think to some degree
you mean literally yes like you're safe
from a lot of I mean even we never had
the sexual assault stuff I read a lot
about sexual assault women who are of
the same age who are not students who
are not on campus or at a higher
likelihood of suffering sexual assault
right yeah we hear all the time there's
a rapid EMA campus right so I think when
you have sort of smaller grievances than
the average population but you have this
immense bureaucracy
that is supposed to be meeting your
needs I mean I toured Arizona State
University for this book beautiful
campus you know very happy place sun
shining every five feet there's a sign
saying are you doing okay did you
remember to breathe today like do the
students they don't know how to breathe
like you should go you're not okay you
should go to the Counseling Center there
there's a perfect trouble breathing very
you know most not all student but these
very privileged people and being told
that there is something wrong with them
on a sort of psychological level and I
think so I think there's an openness to
talk about mental health on campuses
that has gone maybe too far again people
who who need help I'm glad they can get
it I'm glad it's been D stigmatized so
that people can talk about it when they
do need help but there's almost a like
you you want to see something wrong with
yourself because also that now gives you
standing in the activist community
because the intersectionality is the
other kind of big phenomenon I talk the
intellectual phenomenon which holds that
you know the oppressed are the experts
on their own oppression so within a
circle of activists the person who has
the most layers of oppression is going
to be looked to for guidance no one else
is allowed to speak on these issues in
fact and considering I'm talking to a
cisgender heterosexual male right now
this is I know I don't know why you
really got some nerve yeah they're gonna
love this interview two white men
talking about this well so one way to
have some a so if you don't like meat if
you don't satisfy any of these
marginalized characteristics but if you
have a sort of mental or emotional issue
if you have trauma if you have PTSD well
that's a marginalized category and
you're sort of being encouraged to see
yourself this way and to kind of look
for something like that I mean I've read
sort of biographies of like
administrator activist type people on
campus where the first thing they tell
you about themselves is that they suffer
from PTSD which again I don't think this
is something you should be ashamed of if
you if you have this you should
absolutely get your help but you know
I've talked to professors who are like
there's no way every single member of my
class at a prestigious liberal arts
university my very wealthy students
actually have PTSD there's no way like
it's just in politics
when they asked me for like exam
extensions and homework right and things
like that and they're saying it's
because I had PTSD and you've said
something that triggered it in class
like there's just no way it's every
student but professors I'm interested
for this book told me they had that
experience so what are the professors
doing because there's always this sort
of chicken and the egg thing and the
inmates are running the asylum and it's
like well who started this is it the
professor's that started this that are
now getting their comeuppance so this is
something I think that separates me from
some of the other people who talk about
this stuff particularly on the right
there's this idea among conservatives
that
yeah professors are brainwashing their
students I think so first first of all
professors are terrified of their
students they're just utterly terrified
of them for good reason
because it only takes one and again I'm
not typing when I the problems I'm
talking about it's not this is not all
students naked most students this is a
small fringe number of students that all
of a sudden have tremendous power mhm
and are getting whatever they want and
it just takes so just takes one of those
in class and you're going to have a
title 9 complaint filed against you if
you said anything having to do with sex
or gender again these are very far left
professors getting these these
complaints from their students because
they've sort of rostered this atmosphere
I mean that's the IR you mentioned Brett
line stuff before but that's that's the
irony
evergreen basically was thought of as
the most lefty progressive school in the
entire country yeah so you'd think if
those ideas are about you know if those
are truly about diversity and inclusion
and freedom you'd think it would be a
bastion of those things there but these
students are learning it from other
students and they're learning it from
students at other campuses
I guess social media there in Facebook
groups together they see what the kids
at Berkeley did or at read or at Oberlin
and the kind of ideas there's a there's
a vocabulary around activism there's a
you know an appreciation for a couple
older sort of activists here like Gloria
Steinem or someone like that you know
there'll be a picture of her with a
quote shared in a Facebook group that
somehow you know pertains to kind of
their safety activism so they're
learning more from each other I think
than they are they're learning from a
couple professors in some activist
disciplines that have proliferated in
the last thirty years but for the most
part they're really rad
lysing each other
[Music]